[Music]
what is braixen
you know when the vote was announced the
result of the vote I was really pretty
shocked
basically I just feel that it's a step
backwards you know we've been in the EU
for more than 40 years now and it's
going to place us back where we were in
the 1960s basically really yeah
obviously some things have changed but
it's the kind of mentality that goes
with it which I cannot worry about
particularly why did this happen well if
you take immigration for example there
are actually no votes in a politician
saying well actually we need immigrants
to keep the country running and so this
is brexit is a sort of British
independence movement and it is
sometimes characterizing those terms
that you know like a country which has
been colonized and finally becoming
independent which is really sort of a
completely ridiculous way to view it is
there a connection between brexit and
what we've seen happen and for
recently I do see some parallels
particularly with this British
government after the referendum the
government has become much more
authoritarian in quite a lot of ways and
I think that's a result of the brexit
vote and the 2-year time limit or
negotiating with the EU what we're
seeing is an attitude which face similar
to what we've seen in some of the Arab
countries regarding the Arab League
which was their kind of hopes founded on
the problem of national sovereignty and
again we come back to borders and
borders are not you know passports had
not actually been in existence for that
long you know even in Europe you know
it's only sort of 200 years or so since
some countries were unified into what
they are today but people weren't
traveling as much nothing but as it you
know the original British passport was a
letter from the king or queen saying you
know please allow this British subject
to travel in your country do you have
one of them no I don't have one of those
no no I would imagine you have to be 200
something years Uub would do yes yes but
but in all seriousness your point being
borders may not necessarily deserve as
much emphasis and I think I think that I
think that's right because the more
interdependent countries become the less
less borders matter are you surprised by
well I'm surprised by what's happening
in the West in the our world I I think
I've been watching for so long as I'd
rather got used to the way things are
there and you know you see some hopeful
signs
but change if it's coming is really
pretty slow now what we've seen both
with Trump and in Britain with the
brexit referendum is a kind of backward
movement it's it's a kind of resistance
to globalization which about again I
think is rather futile I don't think
it's something you can resist because of
the way the world works countries are
becoming more and more interdependent
and so you can't just do whatever you
want within your national boundaries you
know the classic example is something
like global warming you know where if
all you know what you need is an
agreement where all the countries make
some contribution to reducing emissions
and that sort of thing and you can't
really have one or two who decide that
they they don't care about it we have on
our doorstep a market which is pretty
stable you know it's the democratic
countries they respect human rights on
the whole I mean not as perfect but
their best a lot of other countries and
you know you can be it's a fairly secure
market right basically but we're turning
our backs on for this kind of great
adventure supposedly and the Prime
Minister saying Britain is going to be
open to the world and then she rushes
off to Riyadh or somewhere and you know
the government has ministers have made
quite a lot of trips to the GCC states
since the brexit referendum and they are
very helpful of getting a special trade
deal that would that be a way to soften
the blow then breaks that in terms of
the boy economic country well yes yes
they're talking about I think I think
it's fairly clear that whatever happens
in the negotiations Britain is going to
lose a certain amount of trade with the
AU so they're looking for ways to
compensate and obviously the Gulf states
are wealthy so they have plenty of money
to spend so try and get it get them to
spend it with Britain what concerns you
about that the sovereign wealth funds
have gone on increasing the amount of
property they own that in Britain things
like football Cubs as well and of course
with brexit Britain playing to leave the
EU the British government has been
pressing to divert relations even
further with the Gulf Cooperation
Council States I think that's something
we should really really pay cautious
about because the opportunities for
trade are mostly focused on sales of
weapons and weapon the weapons trade is
not something which is particularly sort
of reliable in the long term so it has a
sort of unpredictability factor which
you don't get with say car manufacturing
and things like that and it's subject to
politics as well very much what we've
seen is that the British government has
been making overtures to a lot of other
countries of possible trade pips and
China as well
without apparently being too concerned
about the nature of the government in
those states and also you know you don't
know how steady that relationship is
going to be because they can be you know
a relationship built a country like
china is going to actually going to be
more volatile than a relationship say
with France or Italy like that that's
fairly obvious